leading theoretical physicist Michio
Kaku has spent his career analyzing time
he believes a working time machine is
inevitable we now believe that space and
time are not invisible they're actually
a fabric a fabric that can be stretched
pulled and perhaps even wrapped up into
knots
if so then perhaps the dream of time
travel is not as preposterous as it
sounds to build a time machine we must
find a way to manipulate this space-time
fabric many scientists believe that it's
this manipulation that will make time
travel not only possible but inevitable
Geneva Switzerland
this is CERN the European Organization
for Nuclear Research home of the world's
largest particle accelerator scientists
from 85 different countries study the
subatomic world to understand how the
universe works
at this space-age facility they have
been carrying out time-travel
experiments for more than 40 years
a useful time-travel particle is the
muon
muons are high-energy particles produced
by cosmic rays which constantly bombard
the Earth's atmosphere muons live for
only about a millionth of a second here
in CERN scientists use speed to make
these subatomic particles live longer
ultimately turning them into Time
Traveller's giant accelerators like this
one at CERN push the muons two
velocities approaching the speed of
light if we have a moon traveling in a
ring at close to the speed of light its
life time is prolonged that means that
the clock which the moon is is ticking
slowly slowly slowly
so when the moon comes back it has only
gone through tic-tac tic-tac tic-tac
while we have gone it can't attack
tic-tac tic-tac so in a sense the moon
is coming to our future because only one
second has elapsed for the moon 20
seconds has elapsed have elapsed for us
by slowing down the rate of time
scientists enable muons to time travel
into the future
the main problem with using speed to
time travel is that we can't move an
object anywhere near to the speed of
light it would take all the Earth's
energy resources just to push our rocket
to a tiny fraction of the speed of light
but you wouldn't notice any difference
unless you got very close to the speed
of light itself we simply don't have
enough energy and there's another
problem using speed to build a time
machine is a one-way journey into the
future traveling close to the speed of
light will enable time travel to the
future but the time traveller has not
mastered time he has merely slowed down
his own rate of time and fast-forwarded
himself through time he wouldn't be able
to come back to tell his tale